Hello, I'm Christine Oliver.
I'm the Green
Party parliamentary candidate for Dover and deal.
I love this area.
I've lived here since I was 14.
I went to school here,
I work here,
I volunteered here,
and I'm raising my family here.
So I really understand the local context
and the problems that the people who live here face.
I know from speaking to people on the doorstep
that they're really
concerned about the cost of living crisis,
but also at the climate crisis
and the biodiversity crisis, too.
The Green Party is the only party that has the policies
to address these problems in tandem.
I think it's really,
really important for the people of Dover
Deal and the surrounding villages
to have the opportunity to vote for
policies that put people and the planet at their heart.
So please support this
crowdfunded
with what you can
to give the people of Dover
Deal and the surrounding villages
the opportunity to vote green in the upcoming
general election. Thank you.